the president has received the council's
position from its first reading also the
reasons behind adoption of that
and the positions and opinions of the
commission have also been received the
complete title of this will be
published in the minutes of today's
session the three-month deadline that
the parliament has starts today the 17th
of March 2023
then we have a further announcement
following the resignation of Mr Eric
Andre Eric Andrea and on the proposal of
the committee on legal Affairs
Parliament takes no to the vacancies of
his seat from the 2nd of June 2023 in
accordance with the rules of procedure
will inform the National Authority
concerned thereof okay that brings us on
to the agenda for today
first of all on our agenda we have the
European citizens initiative save these
and Farmers towards a b-friendly
agriculture for a healthy environment
we will start with Mr a count for the
environment committee you have the floor
sir
thank you madam chair and good morning
to you all we are discussing today a
European citizens initiative that got
more than one million verified
signatures
and the title of that initiative is save
the bees where everyone is of course
very much concerned about but I think
also very important save the farmers
and for very sure I know that we will
have a discussion again about our
farming model but what the citizens are
aiming for here also is by changing our
agriculture model we can save the bees
and the farmers at the same time and for
me that is always a pretty uh strange
part of the discussion that I have here
in this house when we are discussing
agriculture I don't meet anyone who is
happy with the developments in our
agriculture system we see that young
farmers are more and more reluctant to
get into this business we see that less
and less farmers are there and that
they're getting bigger and bigger but
that the profits are shrinking so no one
is really happy with the current
agriculture model doesn't that mean we
need a substantial change a substantial
change that benefits the farmer but also
benefits our natural system which our
agriculture system is built upon and
that is exactly what this initiative is
trying to put forward and that's also a
call to the commission to do now
something about the change of our
agriculture system and of course the
commission launched its Farm to Fork
initiative which by the way was very
well supported by this house as well
but now the question is what are we
going to do with the farm to Fork
ambition yes there is one file out that
is the sustainable use of pesticides and
you see already and probably some
colleagues will mention it again there
is not full support for that proposal
and some even want to get rid of it that
would mean there is nothing of the farm
to Fork strategy then on the table then
what's your plan you will stick to
business as usual with the model you're
not happy about so something needs to
change and this is really a question to
the commission what are you going to
propose to change not strategies not
initiatives not nice reports but laws to
change to make us less dependent of
pesticides fertilizers antibiotics
because that's the model that needs to
change for the bees and the farmers
thank you very much
thank you very much the next speaker on
behalf of the agriculture committee Mr
Lynch president commissioner dear
colleagues bees
are an essential part of our ecosystem
without bees there's no food but in if
farmers are also an important part of
our ecosystem without them uh there's no
Harvest there's no food and so for that
reason it is important that we work
together with them with all of the
farmers we need to talk about practical
implementable Solutions we need to work
together with the farmers
in cooperation and not in confrontation
because we're going to have to make
decisions if we are too idealistic then
we won't achieve the objectives that
we've set the European citizens
initiative safe bees and Farmers towards
a bee friendly agriculture shows how
important this matter is to European
citizens
but the question is how can we protect
bees and farmers in the long term and I
can only say that is something we can do
with dialogue we need Alternatives and
we have to come up with these
alternative substances and then we can
talk about reduction
and we need the commission to be on
board with this and when we're talking
about biodiversity and how we maintain
or improve biodiversity then we have to
talk about family businesses many of
them complain that they're being pushed
into the background and that farmers are
stopping but there are lots of Demands
on them documentation that mean that a
smaller Farmers simply stop farming and
that there's no future generation taking
on the farms and in my region
baden-wurttemberg we are trying to take
the path of cooperation we have a
legislation on biodiversity and I think
that the commission should have a look
at this in more detail
because at the moment we're in a bit of
a dead end
thank you very much now miss Miranda for
the petitions committee
thank you very much president
commissioner
first and foremost I should like to
congratulate those who took the
initiative for the citizens initiative
it is absolutely a success and on behalf
of the petitions committee we would like
to offer you our support more than a
million citizens stated that this is a
priority for European citizens
therefore we need to
make sure that we follow up on these
important initiatives of citizens
participation in participative democracy
and that is the case in terms of the
organization of this they made a request
to us that we would have more done to
save bees there and Farmers to support
our environment and to make sure that we
have healthy food and a healthy
environment they made a request for us
to to make sure that we bolster our
policies to better protect farm land to
make sure that they are a driving force
in biodiversity protection
support to Farmers
is needed as is support for the
environment biodiversity farming
supporting small farms smes a
sustainable and organic farming
research and development for pesticide
free farming as well as GMO free farming
the petitioners
pointed for example to the importance of
making sure that we restore our
ecosystems now we support a full
protection of bees and other pollinators
that are currently suffering a dangerous
decline one that is underscored in
Europe but around the world as well many
bee species are under threat the
populations are falling some
80 percent and some 40 percent are at
risk of endangerment
this decline is due to several things
and the European citizens initiative
is a great opportunity for the EU to
take a strong measures to stem this
decline in the population
farmers in Galicia very much are
requesting this type of support and we
support it as well thank you
thank you very much now we come to the
commissioner has been mentioned we'd
like to welcome commissioner McGinnis
this morning thank you for being here
you have the floor Madam Madam president
good morning colleagues um like the
farmers of Europe we're up early and
having this really important debate and
for obvious reasons I'm very happy to be
taking this very important debate
um this European citizens initiative is
talking about saving bees and farmers
and we've heard very strong
contributions from the environment
committee the agriculture committee and
the petitions committees so I want to
congratulate the members of those
relevant committees for a very
successful public Hearing in January on
this topic because allowed the
organizers to present their initiative
and for members to express their views
and I think today's plenary debate is
also about exchanging views on this
topic it also shows that the European
citizens initiative can be very much
agenda setting and it allows citizens to
shape the public debate on critical
issues for the European Union
our citizens are increasingly concerned
about the use of pesticides and the
buildup of pesticide residue in the
environment
society as a whole including Farmers
want to see less pesticide use and lower
risks
we also saw this in the calls from the
conference on the future of Europe and
indeed other European citizens
initiatives
we anticipate that they recently updated
EU rules for approving microorganisms
for use in plant protection will
facilitate more access to biological
alternatives to chemical pesticides
we also need to acknowledge that farmers
need workable alternatives to allow them
continue to supply consumers with food
in addition the revision of the EU
pollinators initiative adopted in
January and the upcoming revision of the
B guidance document for pesticide risk
assessment will boost protection for
bees and wild pollinators
recent analysis carried out by the jrc
shows that biodiversity loss is a major
threat to EU food security
it already affects our agriculture
sector with potentially irreversible
impacts in Europe and globally
we have lost so much nature already but
just protecting what we have is no
longer an option we really have to step
up efforts not only to preserve but also
to restore nature and to reverse
biodiversity loss
this will help to improve essential
ecosystem services like pollination and
Pest Control
honorable members you will decide on two
commission proposals on the regulation
on nature restoration and the regulation
on the sustainable use of plant
protection products
I would ask you to keep this citizens
initiative in mind in your decisions
European citizens expect an ambitious
outcome and substantial progress in the
transition towards sustainability
this initiative also raises key
questions as to how farmers can play a
central role in the transition towards
more environmentally sustainable
agriculture
and it calls for an increase in
agroecological and organic practices
the new common agriculture policy
entered into force in January this year
it has significantly higher
environmental ambition compared with the
past
it provides a combination of obligations
for Farmers to be able to benefit from
cap support
and it supports more demanding practices
allowing reduced pesticides the
development of organic farming the
creation of new landscape features and
other environmentally friendly
agricultural practices
the new regulations if ambitious and the
new cap if implemented correctly will
help the EU respect the commitments made
at the convention on biological
diversity cup 15 under the new Global
biodiversity framework
we need to solve the nature crisis in
this decade with efforts by everyone for
nature and pollinators for farmers and
for all Europeans
our farmers are custodians of the land
and they are Central to this effort
their Futures depend on it and we should
listen to their concerns
the debate today will feed into our
ongoing reflection
we will present our general conclusions
including the action we intend to take
in our communication planned for early
April and I look forward now to an
exchange of views thank you
foreign
thank you commissioner that brings us on
to the first round of the groups on
behalf of the European People's Party Mr
Dorfman has the floor
thank you
thank you colleagues
the European citizens initiative is an
instrument which helps us to have a
democracy and I think it is a good thing
that uh citizens have an opportunity uh
to express their views and I know how
difficult it is to gather a million
citizens because I worked on a Citizens
initiative in the past protecting bees
and biodiversity is obviously uh
something which is of great interest to
Farmers because many uh
if I'm required these types of plants
but uh
when working with a chemical substances
um The Dangers need to be eliminated
fewer chemicals is in the interest not
only of bees but also of farmers and
also it's an economic question because
these substances cost money but some
people
seem to have the impression that farmers
just use chemical products for because
it's they like them
but we have to look at how they can be
replaced a lot of people who will have
signed the initiative want to have
um
ready access to food and at low prices
if we want to reduce the use of chemical
substances then we need to have uh
substitute the burden shouldn't be of
falling on Farmers because they have no
leeway anymore
we have to ensure that people are
willing to pay more and we see it that
at the moment that's simply not the case
we've got inflation and uh that means
that people aren't buying
um organic products and these are now
being sold at prices that aren't
acceptable for Farmers if people want to
buy local uh products at acceptable
price that would be the best approach so
that would be better than a signing an
initiative because then they would be
helping both the bees and the farmers in
the EU thank you very much Mr doffman
now for the Socialists and Democrats
um
difference
thank you president
congratulations
for this citizens initiative I think we
all agree the title couldn't be better
but a few things I wanted to point to
now we're talking about pollinators
ecosystems and it's very hard for us to
not uh to be able to have long-term
agricultural yield if we don't protect
those two things we know that a huge
proportion of our food depends on
pollinators therefore we have to act
there are two regulations that are
currently underway one is the nature
restoration that would have legally
binding measures for the member states
and the sustainable use of pesticides
regulation now this morning in this
debate we are looking at this subject
but in the subsequent period we have to
really focus on these two types of
regulations there are some points where
we don't necessarily agree and we have
to negotiate to be able to
save our pollinators and that means
we're going to find need to strike an
agreement on these two regulations thank
you
thank you very much now Mr lavacek for
the renew Europe group you have the
floor sir
thank you very much Madam chair
protection of bees and other pollinators
is essential and important not just for
the environment and biodiversity but
especially for sufficient production of
food one of the solutions is undoubtedly
a pesticide reduction sometimes I hear
that farmers love using chemicals they
don't actually it's it doesn't make them
happy to work with it and it costs them
a lot of money but they have to use it
why what is the solution then a less
damaging alternatives are being blocked
by you and plants that don't need so
much chemicals and approving new genomic
techniques is something that we wait for
for years and you who shout that you
have to protect bees you are the ones
who block that so what we need
is a solution which is not easy so
commissioner please propose a b package
that will tackle all these problems
thank you very much
thank you very much now on behalf of the
green group Miss Vina has the floor
thank you very much for giving me the
floor colleagues I'd like to uh start by
uh thanking uh the uh those who started
this is in his initiative it's uh
impressive what they've been able to do
particularly against the background of
the covid pandemic nonetheless they were
successful and managed to introduce this
initiative but I regret that the people
who are responsible for this are not
were not able to participate in today's
debate because
um
as people have said uh we have seen that
uh climate change
um a lot of biodiversity
all of these are linked to our food as a
place with
chain and uh of the importance for
Farmers we need sustainable food change
and so for that reason we need to talk
about transformation about how we can
achieve this and it is important that we
encourage farmers and that we say to
them there are solutions all of these
are available there are agricultural
friendly ways and these will be
um more profitable
and so why aren't these methods being
used these methods that work hand in
hand with nature
because we need to make people aware of
these because our
um if Farmers need to be need to be made
independent from these major companies
and they also need to earn more
we have to talk about organic
Agriculture and this open has a problems
uh the the economic model of one type of
farming is destroying the other type and
for that reason we need to find
Solutions I'm not talking about health
impacts you will know that in in France
and in Italy
Parkinson's disease and other diseases
have been declared occupational
um the illnesses for farmers and they
have uh we need to have a fact checking
please look check your mailboxes you
should have got that yesterday by email
and I would ask you to read this very
carefully and I think that we all I have
to
contribute and not delay we need to take
this seriously because we need to act
now in Vena as next is
the floor
for the European conservatives and
reformist group
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
with this European citizens initiative
save the bees and the farmers
there's a Justified request to give
attention to the pollinators for
Horticulture and agriculture more than a
third of our
crops that go to food is dependent on
being pollinated by honeybees and wild
bees when we use plant protection
products we have to look at how this has
effects on insects
and that means we have to have a very
clear approval procedure and framework
and a speeded up approval procedure for
low risk pesticides
the question of phasing out synthetic
pesticides by 2035 as the citizens
initiative is asking for I think is not
very realistic plant protection products
have to be made available and have to
remain available so that they can be
used if they're any scourges or diseases
that are threatening so we need a mix of
measures we need integrated plant
protection management we need to invest
in robust plants and healthy soil and
how Precision agriculture as well but I
think additional stimulation of good
initiatives on looking at the Legacy for
farmers
dealing for with for example herbaceous
borders and also creating Nest
possibilities for insects would be
useful
but we can only have an integrated
approach that's the only way we can make
sure that we help the consumer we make
sure that we still get enough good and
healthy food thank you
identity
colleagues in the ideal world as
described by European citizens as
entitled uh save bees and Farmers
towards a b friendly agriculture well
that would mean that farming would not
need any pesticides whatsoever but that
is just a dream by reducing by 80
percent of synthetic pesticides in the
dates that are put forth as unrealistic
that plan would save bees but not
European farming and if you do not
believe me all you have to do is look to
see what is happening with beets in farm
and in uh in France and a ecj ruling has
um just um banned neo-nicotinoids now we
know that this type of synthetic
pesticide ban must be done but it must
be done in a sound way with scientific
grounds and not based on random data
this will only be able to be done in
Pace with research that will come up
with substitute Solutions new types of
genomic Studies have some promising ways
forward in the meantime however we have
to avoid a dogmatic approach or a shift
to unrealistic Green Solutions we have
an international crisis and therefore
the EU must have food autonomy this will
mean that we're have to continue to use
synthetic pesticides there and only when
and where necessary
thank you very much now for the left
group Miss hazacamp has the floor go
ahead
thank you very much president Madam
commissioner
I'm standing here with mixed feelings on
the one hand I'm extremely proud that so
many people have been mobilized to
protect bees and Farmers on the other
hand I'm angry I'm angry because this
European Parliament doesn't see the
necessity to have a healthy and safe
food system
bees are being threatened by Massive use
of agricultural poisons but if
pollinators die out that'll have
catastrophic consequences for nature but
also for the production of our food
industrial agriculture which is
dependent on poison and synthetic
fertilizers is threatening the future of
our planet and all the countryside
populations we have I hear there's a lot
of support for the citizens initiative
but in the meantime
the legislation to reduce agricultural
poisons is being sabotaged by this
Parliament the quantities of
disinformation and scaremongering that
we've heard about this piece of
legislation can be compared with the
attempts by the tobacco industry to take
legislation which is necessary to
protect people against lung cancer and
weakening it and delaying it
the tactics of the Agri industry are
comparable
sowing doubt about cause and effect with
the intention of weakening and delaying
I hope the common sense will prevail
we have to act urgently to help bees and
get rid of dangerous agricultural
poisons we have to restore nature
urgently and we have to help farmers to
transition to sustainable small-scale
plant-based and healthy food production
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr jeruso
it's extremely important for European
citizens to have this opportunity to
Forks the European Parliament to discuss
bees which is so fundamental for
human life
farming and the work that bees do in the
world we know that it's worth something
around 130 billion a year and the
portion in Europe is important and
therefore there are four things that we
need to do immediately we need funds to
restore a habitat for uh wildflowers
restructuring the cap for pollinators
and making sure that we repopulate the
population where it has fallen reforming
the pesticides regulation to prevent
future damage to Apes bees and making
sure also that we look at those plants
that are currently being marketed and
respect all of these things our entire
biodiversity is completely at risk were
we to not do something that would be
absolutely unconscionable thank you
thank you very much next speaker will be
Mr bogowicz you have the floor
dear Madam commissioner dear colleagues
I come from Slovenia and I think we can
safely say we are a beekeeping country
we have 11 000 beekeepers
to our 2 million citizens we have a
wonderful
beekeeping organization
that prepared the initiative for healthy
breakfast so every third Friday in the
month uh the young people in our schools
know the importance of healthy
breakfasts from 2011 onwards there were
no B
there was no decline in bees because we
are
um
keeping the rules I also grow fruit I do
use pesticides and for 30 years
I import these to my Orchard do you
and the bees come from my son
he is keeping 10 beehives in our Orchard
every year and no bees have died so far
so I believe we need to respect rules we
need to keep our regulations but also
ensure farmers can use swords that are
resilient we need to focus on precise
farming
and use solutions that have proven to be
effective in other agricultural methods
and farmers are already using them
discussions about doing away with the
pesticides in a very short time frame
are not good either thank you very much
and now Mrs Aguilera
thank you very much president
commissioner McGinnis welcome
well I'd like to really Begin by
congratulating all of those who
contributed to the European citizens
initiative because it shows
the critical spirit that the citizens
have and it's also a request to improve
our well-being of all so congratulations
to the authors this ECI
is requesting a ban on synthetic
pesticides restoration of biodiversity
and assisting farmers in this transition
and I don't think anyone would disagree
with these objectives another thing I'd
like to be
clear on
by 2035 I'm not sure if this is a
realistic uh possibility however
realistic I say
now we need to assist farmers and give
them Alternatives we need to guarantee
guarantee
um vegetal
health
much like human health food security
affordability of food products and we
have to remember that we are currently
undergoing a period of inflation
therefore I think this is a good
initiative but we have to remember the
entire phasing procedure support to
Farmers how would we do that
and how can we make sure it's
agronomically possible because we cannot
just shift things to exports therefore I
agree with everything but I think that
we have to keep in mind that we can't
just look at one side of the balance how
will we support biodiversity yes but how
can we support Farmers to make it
possible otherwise it would just be a
simply simply fiction thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
will be Mr Jose you have the floor
thank you
foreign
commissioner colleagues
not only scientists but also ordinary
citizens have been telling us this very
clearly dangerous and synthetic
pesticides they threaten Farmers bees
but also other pollinators
we have integrated Pest Management we
have biological farming all of these
methods are well known but yet not used
why are they not used
um the permit are being prolonged even
though we know that some of these
pesticides are known poisons the
commission grants these exceptions also
for known banned
nicotineates but these are um
even granted permits for future even
though we know that there are
alternatives so this is also the case in
Slovakia the farmers don't know about
these Alternatives what we lack is
independent advice
and
the Alternatives they are being
um
really blocked
we expect the commission to change their
attitude
and we expect that these poisons will
disappear from our Fields thank you
the next speaker will be Mr grufa you
have the floor
thank you very much Madam president
Madam commissioner ladies and gentlemen
1.2 million citizens from across Europe
uh crying out in despair because of the
terrible agricultural model
just rushing around like headless
chickens is not going to help just let's
just look at the problems that we're
facing obviously without Farmers there
won't be any agriculture but without
pollinators there won't be any
agriculture either by a massive flying
insects has dropped by 76 percent on
average across Europe 82 percent last
summer alone
robots replacing bees is that the future
that you want for our children
it's up to the commission to make sure
that this is stopped and they take their
responsibilities by strictly applying
the European court of justice ruling on
the ban on neo-nicity noise across
Europe
yes to do things differently is possible
the IPM work system was here last
session in plenary that showed that we
can reduce pesticide use by 50
integrated
pesticide use is possible and we need to
have a different policy in commission
and in Parliament so let's stop serving
the interests of industry and listen to
the people of Europe
thank you very much
and Mrs zalesko will be the next speaker
Madam president commissioner I'm very
happy for the title of this debate and I
hope that the commissioner will be
looking at the program in such a way so
holistically because the initiative
which was supported by a million of
signature coaches who would not love
bees and but unfortunately it's a
one-sided approach I come from Poland
and
we have had the base for hundreds of
years we know how to take care of them
let me start with this
when looking at the problem one should
perhaps follow those who have good
results already
although they do apply a plant
protection products nonetheless of
course money is required not only for
small farmers thanks to a Polish
commissioner Mr volchehowski there is
support to Apiaries small ones and big
ones and conflicts must be avoided among
farmers and those who move out into the
countryside and go live in the country
then and I'm very happy this is the
subject we're debating today thank you
very much
thank you the next people will be Mrs
kidoni
grazia president
thank you president colleagues
commissioner
we're speaking of bees today and that
means that we are talking about our very
lives
without bees many crops would not be
able to produce fruits and seeds putting
at risk our biodiversity without
biodiversity
our health and food Security will be at
risk
our farmers are very well cognizant of
all of this they are the ones that are
the stewards of the environment no one
can do that better than them because no
one knows nature better than them it
Cycles it's
rules and therefore the best way to
respect all of that thanks to their
Daily Commitment farmers
are guaranteeing a protection of
biodiversity
a good example is those who work in
mountainous regions that are extremely
complex
through farming and Farmers that we are
able to maintain all of this alive many
communities depend on them fully and are
continue to live thanks to them
to sum up this means that environmental
sustainability is intrinsically linked
to economic and social sustainability
we must support those who work the land
and produce excellent products that is
the best possible way for us to defend
our future and our children's future
thank you for your attention
thank you
the next speaker will be Mrs konichia
thank you very much commissioner
colleagues the Czech Republic with eight
B colonies per square kilometer sees the
highest bee population density in the
world but the last several years have
been catastrophic in the winter times
there are frosts and thaws in quick
succession bees are disoriented if the
temperature outside is above 10 degrees
they start flying they freeze and die
yes pollinators are being threatened by
chemicals poisoned colonies are not a
rarity not anymore even in the Czech
Republic but pesticides are not the only
and definitely not the greatest problem
of beekeepers these days pollinators are
threatened by droughts landscape
Devastation insufficient pollen variety
different structures of the Agricultural
production or crop rotation and we have
to remember diseases as well so we have
to adopt a complex set of measures I am
very very happy that we have now this
seventh very successful European
initiative and I hope that it will not
meet the same fate as the previous
initiatives I hope that the commission
will actually do something this time but
let's approach this complex issue
complexly by doing just one thing we
won't solve anything thanks Buddha the
thank you the next speaker will be Mr
Buddha
thank you very much president
commissioner we welcome the concerns
expressed in the citizens initiative
it's there are hundreds of plants that
are 90 of our Agriculture and a large
part of them require pollination by bees
and so it's a very important point for
the future of Agriculture we need to
protect a
bees for agriculture and also for food
security and we're told that in 2020
there was an
increase in the B population
uh in Romania there was an increase of
approximately 10 percent so there was an
increase in a b colonies even if
pesticides are being used if things are
done in a rational and sensible way the
proposals which are being made
suggest a reduction of the use of
pesticides but uh
that's not something that we can do with
the percentage of 80 percent by 30 30 is
it in we use uh 650 grams per hectare
and then in the Netherlands it's um
higher and so we can't reduce in the
same way
um
and we also need impact assessment and
we need to give a farm as an alternative
uh thank you uh very much uh Mr adios
thank you
the European citizens initiative is a
very important tool for participatory
democracy of our citizens and this helps
them have a central way to have decision
decision making procedures and this
initiative on the protection of bees is
extremely important in light of this
initiative I would like to emphasize
another problem that we might have not
mentioned and bees in Europe are facing
especially in the Mediterranean region
we are I'm talking about Oriental
Hornets that is destroying bees and
causing a lot of problems in
biodiversity in many member states
including Malta and also Italy therefore
it is extremely important to have
initiatives such as this European
citizens initiative so that we can take
action at the European Union level in
order to address problems that need
urgent remedies for example by helping
our
um
Farmers to eliminate the problem of the
Oriental Hornets it is also important to
address other problems such as climate
change for example due to drought in
Malta two years ago we had
we had 80 percent less honey production
production in one year therefore I think
it is important to address these
problems because without bees we do not
eat without bees our biodiversity will
end thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
will be Mrs Reese
Madam president Madam commissioner more
than a million Europeans citizens of
Europe have demanded that we save the
bees and the farmers we must listen to
them and there are three things that are
important that they're saying to change
reality phase out synthetic pesticides
by 2035 now to be frank I'm not sure if
we'll achieve that but reducing our
dependence on pesticides is self-evident
in a previous resolution on pollinators
in 2019 we asked for that there is a
proposal from the commission on the
table to cut by half chemical pesticides
by 2030 the parliament has to stop
filibustering and
start working the second demand is
supporting Farmers now that's obvious in
financial terms yes but also by making
sure that there's a massive development
of alternatives to chemical fertilizers
the third demand which is essential is
restore pollinator populations That's
essential
now we can see that there's change in
soils intensive farming methods
parasites climate change the fight to
save our bees as a global fight we need
to change course and that's what the
petitioners are asking
thank you very much Mrs I know Mrs
dipani grunenburg you have the floor
foreign
first of all
uh perhaps we could uh uh you could uh
um
Mr Burton just talked about a green
Ayatollah and I think uh we in need to
make sure that this is noted and that
the response is appropriate now uh these
are much more than honey they are
actually the basis of our life
and they make sure that we have
um plants
and food and if we don't have food we
have no Agriculture and or food security
with uh bees are dying out well losing
two-thirds of our Apple Harvest and how
serious does it have to get pesticides
kill bees they damage our environment
and um it's a very uh short-term
approach but without pollinators you
can't have food you can't have
Agriculture and we're working on the
reduction of uh pesticides and halving
by 2030 has to be the absolute minimum
and that is what citizens are calling
for thank you
foreigns were used yesterday in the
um debate yesterday and there was no
comment made on it by the head of your
group and so and we will will be taking
the approach that we decided the next
speaker will be Mr yurgil
y
I would like to
thank us all for the support for the
citizens initiative we should also add
to the title and the aspect of
guaranteeing the safe and secure food to
Consumers
eighty percent of our crops depend on
pollinators this means that farmers and
beekeepers constitute a one coherent
Community they need to cooperate taking
into account all the initiatives that
have been taken I support I invite us to
undertake work on and the directive
which would imagine introducing a good
farming practices and a reduction in the
application of aggressive pesticides we
need to support pollenizers we need to
establish parts of fields which would be
left set aside in order to provide
Refuge to animals and
insects we need also to work harder on
combating
insects and parasites in that decimate
bees I believe that we need to support
the cooperation between farmers and uh
thank you very much Mrs Limer next
foreign well let's just look at what the
alliances behind the European citizens
initiative
movers you've got
dozens of political Lobby groups behind
this bio labels Cirrus
activators or
um
Extinction Rebellion left-wing
extremeness
people with uh
questionable backgrounds or pan Germany
NGO their pesticide Atlas has been
called a
a reference work
Mr Veena one of your foundations on the
save the bees and Farmers is also
involved here and the biomarketing
um online has been
questioned because their questions of
political influence here were we not
just talking about problems with
lobbyism and how we dealt with it now
without plant protection measures we
have uh drastic reductions in yields of
course they're using things like dying
bees and they're always going to capture
Headlines by doing that it's not helping
citizens at all really
what the problem is is that money and
here we can see where the problem really
lies and our task is not to make people
feel good it's to ensure that food
security can be provided
thank you the next video Mr sorry to
Alvarez
president commissioner McGinnis
every time that this house discusses
farming and in this case based on an ECI
on saving bees and farmers
what we usually are trying to do is to
save Farmers but actually it seems like
they want to just completely go back to
the starting point everything that we've
achieved in some 10 years and we've seen
that we've been able to reduce our
pesticide use significantly by using
Innovative technology technology and
precision farming why because Farmers
want to spend less on ppps and they want
to make sure also that they are
protecting biodiversity so important for
their survival in the Epp we support
this we would like to continue to
improve the quality of our products and
our agriculture system in Europe but we
need to be able to feed some 450 million
people and some outside of Europe
so before we make any decision that
would put at risk our food security we
need to have affordable realistic
Solutions and enough time such that
farmers can adapt
we also will need impact assessments on
the socio-economic uh fallout of any
measures that we take
now over the course of decades we have
protected Farmers let us continue to do
that and let's continue to support them
thank you thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
will be Mrs Arena you have the floor
thank you very much president
with the link between uh the destruction
of pollinators and the use of a
synthetic
um pesticides is clear and there is a
consensus by uh scientists and we've
been highlighting these dangers for over
decades the dangers for our ecosystems
and for food security and those who say
that if we don't uh use pesticides we'll
have problems I'd call on you to read
the scientific reports which say quite
the opposite this initiative is at the
echo of what scientists have been saying
for years and so for that reason it's
very welcome here in Parliament it has
been said there are alternative methods
and it's when these methods are used
they are able to reduce uh by 80 the use
of pesticides and so let us help farmers
to use these Alternatives but we need an
ambitious text on the reduction
we need the text now before it's too
late thank you
thank you very much and the next speaker
will be Mr vitsig
save bees and Farmers that's a very
accurate title representing yet another
successful citizens initiative focused
on the environment it's also about
saving Farmers to the practices that we
are supporting are destroying bees
Exterminating life in the countryside in
the very essence of farming we have to
talk about how many and which pesticides
need to be phased out let's not argue
whether it's necessary or not let's
rather speak about how much and what
kind of land is necessary to be
regenerated let us look for ways how to
educate farmers and facilitate them in
their transition
to organic farming I think that we have
a beautiful weekend ahead of us flowers
snowdrops a bees and the like so enjoy
this spring magic and Ponder on why and
where this is happening because where
bees Thrive also people thrive let's say
the bees and the farmers thank you thank
you very much and the next speaker will
be Mr rights you have the floor
thank you madam president commissioner
thousands of beekeepers the losses of
honeybees many of them losses towards
pesticides are replaced year by year but
wild pollinators tested in German
environmentally protected areas show up
to 16 different pesticides we have a
massive decline of wild pollinators and
while Farmers have developed a lot of
strategies to massively reduce the use
of pesticides some here in the house
still have not understood which
direction we are going the future of
Agriculture is one that works with
nature and not against nature so to put
it clear for everyone to understand no
nature no Farmers no food thank you
thank you
thank you very much Mr kuch Milk is next
you have the floor
thank you madam president commissioner
the title of this debate is adequate to
the problem because bees are responsible
for one third of the world production of
food so they are necessary in the
process of production in agriculture on
the other hand one should also remember
about Farmers their future as well
because over the last 10 years
we lost 3 million farms in the European
Union
we should approach this problem
reasonably not with radical Solutions
because that's unnecessary let me remind
you that the proposals put on the table
by the commission with cutting pesticide
use they are inacceptable Mr Buddha
spoke about it already it cannot be the
case that
if you have very different levels of use
of pesticides than cutting by 50 across
the board it's it's not defendable and
that was what was proposed by the
commission we need support for Apiaries
for beekeeping precise farming and
Common Sense on top of that thank you
very much
thank you very much the next Peak it
will be Mrs Bruner
to save bees and farmers and I would
also add consumers we need to regulate
pesticides
with the Agro ecological solutions for
example rotating crops to avoid pest
development
and to make sure that there are the
right kinds of predators
to use bio pesticides that are organic
to avoid pests and to fight ins insects
or uh
as well as mushrooms and uh fungi these
things are possible and also pursuant to
the revised cap
will we have enough funds however for
our farmers
I put the question and the reply was on
unfortunate according to the cap that
will very much depend on the commitment
of member states we have to state that
those who are the most virtuous
environmentally speaking are not
receiving the uh economic support and
yet we know that their systems depend on
it
thank you very much the next speaking
will be Mrs sander you have the floor
president commissioner
yes it is true that bees are essential
for life on Earth and ferment any
biodiversity and we need to mobilize to
stop their Decline and
reverse the trend
and we reformed the common agricultural
policy and allocated additional resource
to the B sector I would also like to
welcome all of the initiatives which are
being undertaken uh locally I'm thinking
of what happens here in Alsace there are
many uh initiatives which are closely
involving the world of Agriculture to
work together with a beekeepers and Test
new ways of working as legislator we
need to be realistic and we need to
admit that we will not change all of the
industrial agricultural policies and
human activities
um so quickly
and we're not simply going to click our
fingers and change the system but we
need to think together and I would
stress together about practical measures
they need to be feasible we need to
protect biodiversity and protect these
this is calls for research Innovation
new technologies
but ladies and gentlemen colleagues
it is important that we involve all
stakeholders and involve Farmers with us
it can't be something which is done
against them and I think we all need to
be aware of that thank you very much
good morning everyone
commissioner good morning
the next speaker is Carmen avram for one
minute
I'd like to welcome the citizens
initiative having garnered more than a
million signatures their concerns for
pollinators
but we also have to look at
inconsistencies amongst the European
institutions for example there's a
proposal
for nature restoration to protect
pollinators at the same time however
there's an attempt to conclude the
biggest Trade Agreement in Microsoft
are people aware that in Argentina
the bees are being destroyed the most of
any country or that pesticides are being
reduced without any alternatives for
Farmers does the commission know that in
Brazil over 10 years there's been a
doubling of the use of pesticides
a Romanian Farmers know-how important
bees are and that's why they don't use a
lot of pesticides at the same time there
are three million tons of unsold cereal
that they had
and their recompense for that is modest
at best so we need to protect the
farmers
and we need healthy food
and if you share those opinions you
should act accordingly thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
valdo flago for one minute please
thank you
what kind of Agriculture do we need and
what kind of Agriculture must the public
sector support what kind of Agriculture
do we lack in Europe well well like
organic Agriculture and this is
something that the citizens are aware of
so dear colleagues in the whole of our
agriculture we have to take the path
that we have taken in istria and that
means supporting local products of
course this will reduce the use of
pesticides and antibiotics and this will
reinforce small agricultural businesses
we need to provide financial support to
Farmers for organic agriculture
and believe me if we do that agriculture
will be able to function on the market
as well and nature and our consumers
will be thankful because we will have
Protected Their health
it this is our responsibility and
therefore I expect all of your support
So this kind of thinking thank you all
right Mr Fuego
you've got a blue card from Mr so-called
do you
do a subject of course so Mr Sunco
you've got a form
ER
if you miss a flago I listen carefully
to your statement and I agree with you
that the European agriculture must be
based on organic farming
we need to support the citizens who
through this initiative want to secure
safe food but given the economic
insecurities and the inflation and high
prices